ينضم الينا الان من مقر وزاره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه بباريس السفير باتريس باولي
المكلف بالاتصال باللغه العربيه في وزاره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه سيد بطريس ما هو الموقف
الفرنسي من المقترح الصيني هل اطلعت فرنسا
عليه
[تصفيق]
اراضيها المحتله واسترجاع سلامتها
وسيادتها
هذا الرساله اليوم للاوكرانيين ان يهددوا
ونحن كما كرره مرارا رئيس ماكو نؤيد خطه
الرئيس زيلينسكي بعشر نقاط خطه السلام سيد
باتريس
سيد باتريس فرنسا في بدايه الحرب كانت
ناشطه على المسار الدبلوماسيه الا ان
الموقف الفرنسي تحول باتجاه دعم كامل
لاوكرانيا ما هي اسباب هذا التحول
لا ما في تهاجم تحول منذ البدايه منذ اول
يوم الحرب
اكدنا عبرنا عن عن
بلسان الرئيس عن دعمنا الكامل لاوكرانيا
لماذا لان هناك
حرب شنتها روسيا بدون مبرر شعب
لا نقولها ضد دوله مستقله عضو الوان متحده
ولذلك عبرنا عن تاييدنا دعمنا الكامل
لاوكرانيا منذ اليوم الاول وهذا ما زال
حتى الان
سنقف الى جانب اوكرانيا كما اكد الرئيس
مكحوم حتى استرجاع الاراضي
ايوه الرئيس ماكرون كان يتحدث عن ضروره
ابقاء خط اتصال مفتوح مع الجانب الروسي في
بدايه الحرب
طبعا الحوار مهم لكن يجب ان يكون له مضمون
معنى
في الوقت الحاضر
الوقت هو
لمسانده كامله لاوكرانيا في كفاحه الشجاع
لاسترجاع حريته واراده
سيد باتريس فيما يتعلق بدبابات ماري كلير
هل حسمت فرنسا امرها باتجاه تزويد
اوكرانيا بها
اولا يعني ليس لنا اي محظور في
مع الصعيد الدعم العسكري نحن ندرس ونجاوب
على كل طلبات التي تقدمها الحكومه
الاوكرانيه الان حوار وثيق مسمر مع
اوكرانيا في هذا السدد اما فيما يتعلق
بتزويد الاسلحه لنا ثلاث معايير اول اوله
اولها ان
الا تساهم المعدات لاي تسعيد ثانيا ان
تكون مفيده وفعاله هذا يعني
تدريب لاستعمال وصيانه المعدات وثالثا لا
تضعف قدره فرنسا للدفاع عن نفسي
ليس هنا اي محظور ندرس كره طلبات ولذلك
قرر الرئيس تزويد اوكرانيا بمصفحه خفيفه
ايميكس عشره وندرس كره الرباط بدون بدون
اي اي محصور كما كما قلت
شكرا لك من مقر وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
بباريس السفير باتريس باولي المكلف
بالاتصال باللغه العربيه في وزاره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه